vsauce kevin here and i haven't had food
or drink
in days
i'm so hungry and so thirsty and i've
got these bagel bites and this bottle of
mountain dew if i'm equally hungry and
thirsty do i eat or drink
eat or drink
eat or drink eat or drink eat or drink
eat or drink eat or drink eat or drink
eat or drink
and if i sit here paralyzed by
indecision long enough i will
die of starvation and dehydration
technically dehydration first anyway
that's not good this classic decision
theory paradox was created in the 14th
century by jean buridon involving a
famished donkey who dies from indecision
and this whole thing is completely
irrelevant absurd and has no bearing on
our modern sophisticated 21st century
lives right wrong we're faced with one
of the most important choices of our
time everything hinges on what we decide
your future is at stake and in this
period of dissension friction strife and
everything that's going on we need to
band together and elect a president
of youtube after months of debates and
campaigning the people have spoken two
candidates have emerged the macabre
internet archaeologist wang and the
fecult animation goblin psychic pebbles
it is a time
for choosing
let's meet our candidates
[Music]
as your youtube president i promise to
restore this website to its former glory
days it's days of offensive grotesque
brand unfriendly wild west chaos
malicious insults based on intrinsic
attributes that's what his website was
built on copyright schmoppy ray come on
making fun of
this is hilarious vote for freedom and
join the wang gang
all right uh thank you wang
uh let's hear from pebbles
[Music]
as your youtube president i pledge that
every youtuber with over 1 million
subscribers must compete an annual no
holds bar thunderdome style battle
royale where the winner keeps their
channel and all the others are deleted
so i ask you
for a vote for fairness and to join the
cult of pebbles
uh you know we have a great selection of
imported cheeses and that's just one of
the perks i'm not even gonna go on but
yeah there's a lot that's just one
fighting to the death sounds bad but
i do like cheese i don't know who to
pick you though you probably know right
away whether you're in the lawless wang
gang or you want to be lured in by the
cult of pebbles they're so
different from each other that the
choice is obvious or you definitely know
which one you don't want which is good
for the candidates no no it's
surprisingly
not
i've got gas so i'm going to open up a
gas station jake's pump and dump gas
station already exists near the middle
of town it's right next to taco bell
obviously so i'll open up mine further
away we're selling gas as long as the
prices are similar people are just gonna
fill up where it's closest jake can have
all these customers and i'll have all
these no problem right wrong if the two
are far apart and we do pretty much the
same thing which we do we'll be
splitting the customers in this distance
between us so the smaller that distance
the fewer customers i lose to the pump
and dump i get everything on my side of
town and i don't lose anything between
our two gas stations and hey if i run
some amazing gas station sushi promotion
maybe i can even pull some customers
from barely into jake's side of town the
further i am away the more people i have
to convince to choose my gas station and
not his
this is why mcdonald's and burger king
have basically the same menu with their
own spin and even their logos are both
primarily yellow and red and why fast
food places in general are all typically
located near each other it's called
hoteling's law outlined in the 1929
stability in competition by economist
harold hotel stating that it's rational
for two competitors to be as similar as
possible to each other while retaining
their own distinct identity cool time
for wang as your youtube president i
will bring back the five-star rating
system well as your youtube president i
too will bring back the star rating
system but there will be six stars not
five on this issue the two candidates
are pretty close there's a difference
but it's not much hoteling's law happens
with voting it's in a candidate's
interest to be pretty similar to their
opponent to minimize that loss in the
middle hey do you want an apple or an
orange just pick one yeah that's not
very hard you probably like one fruit
more than the other so
it's a simple choice but
do you want this apple or that apple how
do you even make that decision you base
it on the size of the apple
the shape of the apple it's
stem
that's fredkin's paradox the closer two
choices are the harder it is to choose
so at this point i really start to
analyze i dig deep i stress out over
little differences and can even see some
that aren't really there because to make
a meaningful choice
i need there to be a difference and now
you're thinking
this is like a c northcote parkinson
problem and you're right
in 1957 c northcote parkinson proposed
that the more you analyze something the
more obsessed you become with the less
relevant details and forget the really
big stuff he wrote that the time spent
on any item of an agenda will be in
inverse proportion to the sum of money
involved where should i go to college
is a question i put some thought into
and it cost tens of thousands of dollars
what video game should i get is a
question i obsess over and that'll cost
60 bucks at most i'm trapped in the
tyranny of small decisions what
economist alfred e khan called that
hyper focus on the tiny details that
actually gets you further from the
overall outcome you wanted in the first
place and then sayer's law knocks on my
forehead and says in any dispute the
intensity of feeling is inversely
proportional to the value of the issues
at stake like a couple who's constantly
fighting over whether the toilet paper
feeds from the front or the back and
never discusses the mounting credit card
debt from buying old ps1 strategy guides
off ebay
just beat a legend of dragoon recently
it was awesome so
how's that uh president of youtube
choice coming along now that i'm in the
weeds i don't know who to choose i'm
emotionally invested in figuring it out
i go deep on less important details
and i'm kind of starting to lose my mind
so all right all right wait how about
this
maybe this election is not even about me
maybe
i want to do what's best for the world
around me think of a bored family in
texas it's saturday no one's doing
anything the dad suggests they all take
a trip up to abilene an hour away
because he thinks the family will enjoy
it he knows the drive sucks and he'll
sweat the whole time so he's not too
excited but his family they'll love it
he asks his wife and she's happy to go
because she thinks the group wants it
too she asks their son and he says yes
because he doesn't want to disappoint
his parents their daughter doesn't want
to be the only protest vote and at this
point she would lose three to one anyway
so she enthusiastically says yes to and
that's how a family of four
unanimously voted to take a long hot
trip in a car full of sweat and dad's
farts that none of them actually wanted
to take that's jerry b harvey's abilene
paradox and voting for what no one
really wants happens a lot in selfless
democracies but
here's my question is that just a
function of having only two choices wang
or pebbles stay home or go to abilene
it's gotta get easier when you have more
choices right wrong arrows impossibility
theorem shows us that when voters have
three or more different options there's
just no way to get exactly the right
community-wide outcome even if we rank
candidate preferences we've got wang and
pebbles and we could throw in smarter
every day and lindsay ellis and marquez
brownlee and so young and preferentially
ranked them all one through six and we
still would not get the youtube
government we all wanted
so
why should i even bother
and how much do you or i count
anyway
in 1793 french philosopher marquis de
kondresay wrote that in single stage
elections where there are a great many
voters each voter's influence is
very small it is therefore possible that
the citizens will not be sufficiently
interested
to vote look at my plate of sand one
single vote is really the inverse of the
greek sororities paradox where you
remove grains of sand one by one from a
heap here we go
removing grains
one at a time grain two here we go
grain through all right you know what
this is gonna take forever look
at what point does it stop being
a heap at what point does your
infinitesimal vote
add up
to
actually mattering paradox lightning
round if a rational voter relies on
their self-interest to make their choice
the costs of that vote are usually
greater than the benefits anthony downs
paradox of voting adding a new state can
reduce the number of congressional
representatives in another state
apportionment paradox or a state with a
fast-growing population can lose
representatives to a slow growing state
population paradox want to reduce the
use of fossil fuels green policies can
incentivize a short-term rise in
consumption hans vernerson's green
paradox it's
so
hard to make sense
of all this when i add up all the logic
traps and complexities of something that
seems so simple
drink or eat apple a or apple b
hypothetically make my family happy or
tell the truth that i don't want to go
to abilene and neither do they the more
i think about it the
less i'm sure i know
every time we make a choice like wang v
pebbles or vote for a real president
we're subject to all of these hidden
consequences of decision theory and
mine are different from yours you've got
to think about all the options all the
scenarios all the contradictions and all
the fallacies but
ultimately
it's
more important that you don't get stuck
in a cognitive web
of indecision psyching yourself out from
making a choice
at all or you'll end up staring at bagel
bites and mountain dew until you're
a dead gamer donkey
and as always thanks for watching i was
gonna eat it but it's freezing cold so i
am gonna eat i'm just gonna heat it up
[Music]